oh my god
an apocalyptic drive smoldering forests
and
choking air oh my god
this is a journey through malala in
western oregon
a state where millions of acres of land
have been destroyed
fires raging where they usually don't
sparked by exceptionally dry conditions
and unusually strong winds
in clackamas county close to the densely
populated city of portland
a lumber yard easy prey for the flames
residents in talent watched on in
disbelief
oh my god mom this is our house this is
our
garage and this fire it doesn't even
look nearly as menacing on the video as
it actually looks in real life
but there's a big fire in ashland right
now
by night angry red skies
and devastation below
as daylight broke the town almost
obliterated
lexi sulios and her family snuck past
roadblocks to sift through the wreckage
of their home
that was our garage and we had just
stored up
so like thousands of dollars worth of
food over the last
few months because of the pandemic and
we are
like oh we should get our supplies
stocked up for things and all of it just
a waste
oregon's air quality now ranks amongst
the worst in the world
global warming and changes in land use
and fire management
have created a hellish mix tens of
thousands of people have been evacuated
dozens are missing and california is
suffering too
familiar sights now look like they
belong
to another world cordelia lynch sky news